grayscale is the largest bitcoin asset
manager in the entire world gbtc is
quite popular in the market but
grayscale is now trying to turn that
gbtc product that bitcoin trust into a
spot etf there are rumors that it is
going to get rejected by the sec just
like every other bitcoin spot etf
application to date grayscale is now
considering potentially suing the sec if
their application is rejected now as a
reminder we first need to think about
what is greyscale how big and popular is
it they have over 800 000 accounts
across 50 states in the united states
that actually own that gbtc product
about 30 billion dollars in aum but gbtc
is trading at a 25 discount to the
actual assets inside of the fund that's
not good for investors if we go ahead
and we take a look at the actual assets
under management you can see that there
was a massive run-up towards the end of
2020 into 2021 and then after they
stopped taking new capital contributions
we have seen gbtc trade alongside the
value of bitcoin as it has fluctuated in
the market if we then go ahead and we
look at the premium or the discount we
used to see gbtc trade at a massive
massive premium and then it grinded down
until it eventually became negative 25
percent which obviously is hurting the
little investor we've got this quote
here from ceo michael shine in which he
states that when asked whether greyscale
would consider the option of an
administrative procedure act lawsuit if
the sec rejects its spot bitcoin
application he said i think all options
are on the table now remember the sec is
not simply picking on grayscale they
have rejected application after
application for a bitcoin spot etf
fidelity valkyrie skybridge nydik and
many many others but they have approved
bitcoin futures etf from pro shares
valkyrie vanakk and ultimately that's
the question are we only going to have
bitcoin futures etfs or will we get the
bitcoin spot etf now this last quote
from michael shunningsline is pretty
telling where he states it was really a
very exciting announcement that we now
have a bitcoin futures etf out in the
market but unfortunately that has forced
investors into those bitcoin futures
products because those are the only ones
that exist and so now we should turn and
look the sec has multiple applications
there's a 30 billion dollar fund that is
the most popular bitcoin fund in the
world they want to convert to a spot etf
will the sec approve that application or
not i don't know but if they actually go
ahead and deny it just like they have
every other application sounds like
grayscale may have had enough hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time